there is a line and it takes a lot to
for me to call somebody out on this
stuff but when Kobe went after Leon's
dad I was like I don't like that but
this is my theory with that Kobe did
that because his team knew Kobe was not
the same version that he was two years
ago and they got to do something to get
in Leon Edwards head because he's too
good he's going to beat Colby everywhere
and if Leon comes correct he's going to
beat the at Kobe so we got to get him
out of that mindset we got to get him to
fight emotional we got to get him come
forward forward by any means necessary
as far as title shots it's over the the
new waves coming in so damn hot and
there's so much talent is Kobe gonna
take a fight with shot does he want to
go down that
road you know is that is that the plan I
don't know